et pour ouvrir le chat which quand je
suis tout seul c'est difficile d'ouvrir
tous les tchats quoiqu'un peu on peut
tenter on peut tenter
on peut tenter alors attendez on va on
va faire ça et on va aller chercher ce
point comme tv aussi pour aller de chat
ouvert bon je vais essayer de faire
l'exploit de lire tous les tchats en
même temps c'est un exploit ce qui est
un exploit
je me prends la pub des deux côtés c'est
bon la pub est gérée et les chat sont là
alors on va réussir à récupérer le chat
comme ça voilà on est pas mal donc on a
un chacha ce point comme tv on va voir
l'autre chat twitch on va tenter on va
tenter
on va tenter et on est de partout alors
on est là et je puisse le récupérer en
papa août
ok excellent
excellent alors l'idée aujourd'hui du
stream c'est de tester en fait
l'aréna les tournants arena sur les
tournants à rennes ce bel aréna sur sur
check point com alors est-ce qu'il y en
a un à l'est il en rire s 19,8 sur celui
là on va participer et on va essayer
voilà c'est on est parti je parle
comment ça marche c'est la première fois
que j'essaye et on va essayer de
victimiser tout le monde on va faire
l'adversaire allait donc on se montre
tard ian donc un joueur un joueur
allemand a fortiori et on va essayer de
le victimiser allez on est parti on va
essayer de faire une remonte à la de
remonter tout le monde allez allez allez
allez faut jouer plus vite a les boules
un cavale à l'étoile et le maté fois les
le maté rapide
il va sûrement faire rock faire cavalier
m6 n'ont créé par hogg rockets ces cas
là on va prendre le pion on va mettre le
cavalier ici vraiment que j'allais le
maté vite je sais pas comment mater le
plus rapidement possible faut marquer
des points pour lesquels j'attaque la
même chair juste qu'il va partir avec la
dame pour pas laisser faire grand pour
essayer de le maintenir le plus
longtemps possible au centre avec son
roi car à faire flouer trois objectifs
pas sans enjeu les meilleurs comme c'est
de l'empêcher de roque et en fait ça me
fait pas peur on va juste faire food et
6 pendant je réussis pas à créer de
réseaux de maths
peut-être qu alliés laïcs à ypres en h2
on va faire 3 au 7 allée on va pas
protéger le pion je vais aller prendre
h200 va lui laisser comme vous dire
l'objectif c'est de mater vite tu
comprends un peu des risques mais c'est
le beau jeu c'est le beau jeu
j'espère qu'ils tendent rockets
pour la peine ça me faire perdre du
temps on est trop longtemps à gagner
cette partie
on met beaucoup trop longtemps à gagner
c'est n'importe quoi ça va prendre ça
aïe aïe aïe j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
un peu de lag de son côté ça me fait
perdre du temps c'est pas bon c'est pas
vous laisser gagner
next game allez allez faut enchaîner
faut qu'on redonne un adversaire
rapidement la direccte aller dans le
monde arrête son détournant on n'a pas
besoin d'un monde attend les
appariements vous à devoir enchaîner
tout de suite à lessard enchaîne on va
le défoncer lui à l'égout une française
faire une vente d' avance et on va les
attaques à la barbare cavaliers f3 dame
g4 je sais pas bon qu'elle c6 déjà
grosse erreur il faut totalement faire
ces 5
on va faire ses trois on va gérer ça
comme ça on va tout lui balancer voilà
il va jouer à grand regret dit viens
jouer à gran via un petit est bien petit
enfin bessin est le cavalier ou 5 allez
on veut protéger un soir le front g5
avec le foin à trois jeux trop excité
j'ai trop polie de gagner vite et en
fait je suis pas sûr que c'est ça qui me
fasse gagner plus vite possible
blessé le pion vient prendre le pion g2
enfin grimper avec le cavalier e 4 est
en fait en fait on rame
en fait on rame faire ça on va aller
enfin je veux dire qu'il joue pas mal
hein 1400 et joue pas mal il joue même
assez bien
jamas eh bien c'est adversaires ici
alors une bonne position il est mieux
autant il n'est classée que 1400
j'espère que tous les 1400 ne joue pas
comme ça parce que sinon ça va être
pénible bon alors on va ramener la dame
en b si son valet le matc fini de
rigoler mais il joue vraiment pas mal le
mec il joue vraiment pas mal papa paulo
on va mettre la dame ici alors espérons
qu'ils sacrifient la dame
toi qui est plus ou moins obligé de
toute façon et si on va faire le beau
jeu on va faire dame c 'est 3 bessette
aidé à me prouver cette maths on peut
pas mater comme ça remettre la tour en
f1 il a réussi à défendre le match une
fois il a peut-être dame prend g2a y
réussit pas à trouver d'un projet deux
échecs pour mettre un peu de suspense
ça devrait le faire bon très bon joueur
un peu plus vite que ça il faut qu'on
joue un peu plus vite que ça allait il
faut forger une partie faut remonter au
classement on est très loin le leader à
29 points
allez faire commencer à se méfier
chirac 2060 ça devient dangereux
ce juge absent de la game et c'est
peut-être dû au c'est peut-être dû au
stream duo live qui ont peut-être
l'impression de près move et pourtant
à
sans ça pas si vitale et damas quatre
connaît la théorie pour le moment je
crois que je l'aï vraiment je vois les
les délais de coûts parfois six tours un
jeu qui va faire quelque chose avec
avicii ce passif et apsys en fait je
vais prendre direct ok on va faire h4 on
peut faire f5 éventuellement bon il joue
pas mal ça prend vraiment prendre du
kava l'on va mettre la dame en d4 une
salle cavalier peut pas vraiment bouger
à cause de dames g7 mat
bon il peut encore alan h5 ok c'est bien
jouer une nouvelle fois comment ils
jouent très bien cet adversaire qui va
revenir ici ce qui veut faire nul pour
ne veut pas fair use de toutes façons on
va devoir jouer cette finale bat à tours
en c1 pour essayer de bloquer le fou
avec le cavalier 17 qui à première vue
non mais je vous trop bien là pas du
tout sûr de pouvoir battre cet
adversaire ont réussi à glisser avec le
foin à deux peut-être pas te faire f 3
maintenant commence à jouer sur le
clouage de la colonne
on va faire un échec
assurone suite à un joli truc qui a tout
reprend et fo m6 m'a t-il le voit va
faire cinq
voilà ça c'est matt pendant que la tour
en fait contrôler la septième rangée
c'était le mat avec le fou qui en a deux
et le fourrage sy sall et cheikh
brasilians tension se fait dangereux
aussi 2102 ça commence à monter en
termes de lots fait de plus en plus
méfiants alors là comme il n'ya pas
mille cavaliers en c3 on peut jouer le
fond f5 tous assez théorique on va lui
laisser prendre la paire de ouf comme
dirait vlad déjoua il joue avec attaches
trois logiques
donc il me fait c'est ça qui me fixer
des quatre qui est pas mal d'amis 7 on
va essayer de préparer les boums dans
l'esprit de toute façon comme ça c'est
fait on va laisser on va pousser comme
des brutes
madame ont eu six
j'ai un truc comme ça doit pas être très
correct mais bon
bon alors est fair play zinc est ce
voulu il n'y a pas de maths ici alors
prendre une fois là on va se faire
défoncer
donc on va se faire mater on peut rien
faire on ne peut rien faire
bon bah perdre pas mal de points elo
mais notre adversaire a trop bien joué
on a voulu trop en faire et c'est papa
c'est bon sa première fois sur la
réserve wallace méfier des jouer avec
des mecs débat 2100 ils peuvent être
très dangereux ça va être très très
dangereux alors celui là ça devrait
aller
cette petite sensation de là que je sais
pas d'où ça vient
à
on va on va aller essayer de mater vous
et quatre échecs à prendre avec le
cavalier comme ça sur pied un projet
simple avec les pros f6 matt direct et
s'y prend comme ça on va prendre sur
échec on va reprendre le set qui aurait
tout prendre m lecavalier angers 5 voir
le fougueux 4
bon on prend ici le jeu reprend dû
cavaler sur échec mais bon prendre avec
le fou ça le mérite de menaces émanant
des rockets il faut qu'on se dépêche on
est on est très loin au classement
dans le premier a déjà 37 points le
rattrapera pas dans cette arène je vous
mettrais et classement de la reine la
prochaine fois mais on peut pas le
rattraper impossible
à
justice la france et j'ai envie de dire
c'est la reine de l'air française on va
prendre faire quelque 3 comme ça on
n'aura foulé et 5 pour venir attaquer la
dame c'est pas bon ça fout bekkat je
pense qu'on va essayer de l'enfermer
saddam masque ou g5 ok il le voit
malheureusement pas mieux valu commencer
par fou g5 du coup pas grave peut-être
fou bkt théorique en fait on va pousser
comme des malades du fer g5 plutôt pas
du tout fantastique pour le moment
et en plus il joue plus vite que moi
et en plus il joue beaucoup plus vite
que moi ça joue déjà pas mal du tout à
15 cents sur ce site du jazz points
comme genre sont déjà très dangereux à
lui échangé les dames ça va le calmer
on va jouer cette petite finale
le froid de houla il ya le pion et seins
qui tombent
car ce que je suis en train de faire
enfin que je me réveille sérieusement là
donc je n'arrive pas à jouer plus vite
que pour moi il joue mieux et plus vite
j'entends me faire victimiser
je suis en train de faire victimiser par
un 15 s'en aller c'est le festival
je ne prévois pas un coup je fais du
caca mais c'est de partir là bas face et
d'encaisser ça on est la tour n'a pas
essayé de rentrer
sur la 6e ou fédé clouage voilà on va
récupérer sa tour enfin mais moi je
l'avais un peu clairement hop on va pour
pré move tour
ça devrait aller bon allez il faut
continuer le premier à combien est
toujours 37 mais presque 5 minutes on
n'y arrivera pas sasson c'est impossible
c'est impossible
mais ils sont assez forts tous ses
joueurs allaient tactics 35,53
scandinave féret qui a valu à seaska et
c6 allez allez allez allez allez
connaissent toutes les réfutations de
tout qui va prendre on va prendre là on
va faire d'amd 5 préfère fois-ci ciroc
pas dans le détroit
il n'empêche qu'il faut f5 je vais
choper le pion 1
enfin toujours un pion de plus ça ne
déplaît pas d'avoir un pion de plus ce
qui est bien ici alors mettre le fou en
gs is on va faire petit rock voire une
position assez correcte au final c'est
un conte va voir comment il traite ça
voilà un petit clouage ça fait toujours
plaisir alors à gratter saddam
je voulais faire feu dame prend dès 2000
y aurait pris l'an c'est simple ça ça
devrait aller je suis pas qu'on va
gagner sa fuite possible parce que c'est
pas mal
j'aimerais bien qu'ils abandonnent mais
non ce serait plutôt dans l'esprit pour
lui d'abandonner la tap a vraiment
beaucoup de chance de gagner cette
partie
mais bon si je ne peux pas lui interdira
les betty va prendre la tour va les
laisser prendre les deux tours en fait
ça nous simplifier la vie allez vas-y
prend la deuxième aussi non comme s'en
va je veux pas trop l'intérêt qu'il a de
jouer ça n'a pu vraiment beaucoup de
coups là
apprendre
affaire 1,5
on va pousser son roi dans le coin ça
c'est assez élémentaire se met en face
durant on va le maté soit en b 6 sont en
baisse certes observé cette année de
retour plus que deux minutes 13
alors on joue contre sheth brazilian qui
nous avait battus il ya 24 points il
assez fort ce chat brasilians il avait
que trois points quand on a joué contre
lui j'ai pas caler son score dans le
tournoi je pas si on peut le voir mais
il joue pas mal
on va faire roig
à
mais bon dans lequel il joue très vite
et ils jouent très bien celui-là cet
adversaire la mairie très clairement un
meilleur classement
c'est déjà fort grands fermés la dame il
a joué à tempo à six est beaucoup trop
fort pour nous on ne peut rien faire et
surtout un tempo
you absolument toute hâte impose cet
adversaire est imbattable ils ne
réussiront pas
c'est à dire sar est imbattable voulu
abandonner nous ne pourrons rien faire
dans cette chaise brasilians mais je
pense qu'il peut démonter tout le monde
à tempo je pense que chaz brasilians
peut démonter tout le monde à tempo
alors le contre chirag 35 heures quelque
chose une nouvelle fois à l toure a fini
bon on n'a pas réussi à gagner celui-là
a perdu un peu de points et on va tenter
la prochaine
alors la prochaine arena d'une minute
alors où est ce qu'elle est arena arena
arena bullet arena allez hop et comment
ce salon va commencer depuis le début
à commencer contre un italien on va
essayer de faire un bon début
oui c'est pas retomber sur eux sur 13
brasilians ce sera pas mal sinon j'ai
peur km 1 3 1 j'espère qu'on en perde
une troisième création qui demandent
s'ils peuvent eux contre nous mais en
fait c'est pas un stream pour jouer
contre contre les abonnés frites belges
et même si tu as abonnés ben non c'est
cool d'être abonné d'où on est un trésor
d'avoir des abonnés mais on a beaucoup
d'abonnés et si à chaque fois on si tous
les stream ont joué contre des abonnés
seraient serait pas super drôle même si
j'ai pas le j'ai pas le son alors émis
pts n 10 qu'en fait c'est le son qui me
vient pas dans l'oreille et qui me vient
avec l'eau par de l'ordi et c'est plus
difficile quand on entend pas fort ça va
être mieux comme ça cette mue comme ça
de mettre le son dans l'oreille ça le
plus facile alors qu'est ce que je suis
en train de faire c'est dantec dam des 4
ans et plus et 5 pour y aller tout
l'enjeu contre m
yp était saine haïti c'est un joueur
russe
je vais essayer de vous faire inscrire
mais du tournoi un peu plus tard tient
il essaye de [ __ ] le bordel
il arrive plus ou moins bien et surtout
essayer de jouer vite et s'est surtout
joué très vite allez hop il fait changer
d'amour est échangé les dames
alors on va prendre ici une fois avec
leur foi en des six comme ça on va
l'empêcher de rock et on va attaquer le
pion c5 est sûre fouet cette affaire
cavalier e 4 ans à l'échoppé le pion
surprise en apprendre de la tour et on
va venir doubler et normalement on
devrait pas être très loin de la vérité
parce qu'on va tout est changé en des
huit on va encaisser le pion et on va
venir faire f3 et ramener le roi au
centre je pense peu près move rêve de
houla après vous absolument ridicule
puisque on redonne un pion suis pas du
tout eu l'idée de faire faute de fou il
faut dire c'était pas normalement c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'on avait envie de
faire avec les noirs mais ok récupérer
au moins deux pions si fo a peut-être
manqué et des huit ce serait cool on va
récupérer un deuxième pion 1
ça me laisse prendre les pions on va les
prendre il va venir et c'est dans ce
show p1
on va faire un échec deux échecs trois
échecs on va pousser et à laisser gagner
next game vous avez gagné autant sympa
allez nous faut rapidement notre
adversaire on va pas perdre de temps
joue contre beiit haye peut tenter une
ruine attention tiens on va faire plus
on prend un pion prend et foot pro f set
up up petite déviation c'est sympa c'est
sympa c'était cadeau on peut ramasser
les pièces très sympa qu'il abandonne
c'est dans son intérêt à lui
d'abandonner aussi c'est pour ça que j'y
serai sympa c'est dans notre intérêt
mutuel alors s'il veut pas abandonner on
va aller le maté à part faire un petit
échec ne réussit pas vraiment à trouver
le le tranchant pour les maths pour le
moment je suis pas super tranchant je
vais me faire enfermer la dame
non heureusement qu'il ya les prends mes
f c'est très très laborieux pour le
moment mais on serait cool qu'ils
abandonnent quand même tu pas vraiment
ce qu'il fait
l'arrivée d'un premier set mais qu'est
ce que je fais à ma temps de 2 me
précédemment g7 mais qu'est ce que je
fais aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe je redonne
madame mais bon je n'arrive pas à mettre
mon cerveau sur ron c'est trop c'est
trop facile
c'est trop facile je n'arrive pas à
mettre le cerveau sur own il reste sur
off
ça va vraiment réussit pas à m c'est
repoussé
c'est pousser à fond
ce matin on allait cette fois ci il va
falloir mater voilà mais bon c'était
très mal joué de ma part bon allez il
faut il faut enchaîner il faut enchaîner
chef chef nick player 2017 aura fer
russes
on va se faire plaisir on va se faire
plaisir à faire gaffe quand même parce
qu'il a neuf points ce peut être
dangereux
c'est ce qu'il est très souple à ces
foires se méfier de ce joueur essaie
d'aller mettre le cavalier en c2 pendant
il n'empêche
jean ray kelly détroit quand même ainsi
vous je le fous sur sur son flanc kétou
peux pas me permettre de m'en parler de
sa paire de fous je pense assez bien et
maintenant avec le fourneau 6 on va
essayer d'aller taper là la tour prend
ses six qui est très fort heureusement
qu'il prend avec le fou est maintenant
fins de rançon afu des 5 1 qui nous
permet de faire une fourchette
ça devrait aller on va encaisser ça on
va les faire petit rock qu'on va les
sauver le fou
non mais tu ne tour en c2 on va
permettre aux foudres de sortie roulage
simplement on va les protéger notre fou
il part comme ça
et le fou s'échappe en grattant le pion
donc ça c'est bon mais maintenant je
prends le pape après mon retour ces deux
voies la tour ces deux à temps prend à
deux fous des trois tours 2 ça devrait
le faire c'est cool qu'il abandonne une
nouvelle fois mais je crois qu'ils sont
pas d'humeur à ne sont pas là pour
abandonner
ils ne sont pas là pour abandonner
seulement pls mes coups de tours idiot
ok c'est le cam on a continué on est
finalement leader on va peut-être jouer
compte le donc le coleader il faut
continuer on rejoue contre ali péter
scène
on va voir ce que ça donne alors il nous
a joué in board dans un stade où elle à
l'envers de pièces par là alors ce qu'on
peut faire avec nos cavaliers bien du
mal pour le moment bon peut-être une
bonne chose qu'il ait pris ici on va
essayer d'aller mater sur la colonne h
parce qu'on peut prendre comme ça on va
essayer d'aller avec du damage si ces
dames h un math
voilà on arrête la dame en rage 6 et on
va essayer d'aller mater notre
adversaire alors si je fais dame prend
effet puis on prend ya pas de maths je
peux faire cavalier prendre 3
éventuellement a pu prendre h 4 aussi c
est peut-être faire damas catéchèse
croix et fuite et je vais maintenir
toutes les menaces auxquelles dans ces
cas là on va prendre ici et on va
prendre ici et on va te retrouver une
nouvelle fois avec une tour de plus
quand même 2 allons voir perdre le fou
dans ce paragraphe celui-là c'est bien
parce qu'ils abandonnent donc ça c'est
la bonne nouvelle on reste toujours
égalité avec destine ait à on rejoue
contre chirag chirac 35,53 a déjà joué
tout à l'heure dans le tournoi précédent
elle avait battu deux fois
y'a pas de raison que ça ne continue pas
d'un co qui on va jouer avec dame b 6
tiens on va faire avec la c4
je pense en plus dans cette vente que le
coup j'ai trois n'est pas utile alors là
on peut pas faire pour le moment fut f5
parce qu'après d'emprunt f5 dame prend
b2 ya dame ses huit matches on est
obligé de commencer par cavalli c'est
ici c'est va sûrement faire cailler d2
voilà qui va nous empêcher de faire
flouer 5 parce que ça a libéré la tour
c'est pour ça que j'ai fait j'ai 6 pour
réussir quand même à faire flouer 5
mètres le fourrage 17 après on va
préparer
b5 et b4 alors on va prendre ça c'est
plutôt bien pour nous plutôt content
parce que ça libère classe b 5 pour le
pion on va pouvoir faire rapidement à 5
et b4 comme ça on a réussi notre
expansion et lui son coût au cas très
rares pas mal de mal à le jouer mètres
la tour en a c'est de pouvoir venir en
baisse puisqu'il ya le fou ici qui gêne
enfin que le cavalier e 4 pour empêcher
à la tour de préparer qui je le reprends
du fou c'est vie c'est l'adversaire va
mettre la tour en b 7 ou 8 d'ailleurs on
peut aussi faire tour à 8 ici peut-être
un coût éventuel
on va faire ça comme ça il va prendre
ces quatre je vais prendre dans ces cas
je vais faire tout reprend à deux tiens
c'est joli mais ça ça parait grand chose
il va permettre ça tours en verre bien
je voulais faire tour prend b2 en fait
pour choyer sur les sur le mat sur le
mag du couloir 1
ok donc on va prendre une fois et on va
faire b2 et on va vouloir faire tourin
en force et je pense que c'est imparable
tiens ça c'est assez joli comme
combinaisons tactiques pour les gens qui
regardent pour jouer sur le mag du
couloir
c'était un assez joli enchaînement est
finalement réussi en force à faire damer
maintenant on fait 5 comme ça on va
complètement enfermé le fougeux trois
points à prendre à une dame de plus mais
juste pour montrer quand même le pattern
qui permet de bien bloquer le fou tout
simplement aller chercher de plomb des 6
et c'est fini hamon a plus beaucoup de
temps pour ça qu'ils continuent à jouer
pourquoi mettre la dame sur blanc va
jouer uniquement notre dame sur casse
blanche au moins on est sûr de passer à
faire manger sain joue que sur des cases
protéger la mecque le turiaf 4
attention il y aurait pu avoir pâte pas
mal joué de sa part elle est prévue par
m6 y aurait eu pattes
on a réussi à ne pas pas tu es tu à
prendre des points alors est ce qu'on
domine le tournoi enfin des décramponner
destine ait 462 et on continue notre
chemin
alors on joue contre ms cms et bdp de
hongrie
et pourquoi pas alors attention est ce
qu'on va être quand même confronté à une
à une ruine le pion aux cinq fait une
espèce de française où il aura pas jouer
ces cinq peut-être faire cavalier pk tu
pas sûr d'avoir bien joué pour le moment
même on va pousser les pions à fond
c'est tout ce qu'on sait faire un
balancer des pions pour plutôt ses
fruits pour le moment mon gros qu'elle
lui aussi balance ses pions alors envie
de dire très bien tout le monde balance
ses pions
qui aurait fait refouler cinq ans à
venir cloud et semble menacée tout
reprend à 7 en fait
ok il se défend peut-être quand même
prendre et venir ici qu'ailleurs f4 pour
le moment je vais placer mes pièces car
f4 bien placé ce qui menace le pion aux
6 on va prendre et faire h3 j'imagine
pas obliger un j'aurais pu prendre en g3
va prendre six
juste faire attention de pas se prendre
une contre attaque avec un sacrifice
quelque part mais bon normalement ça
devrait aller le cavalier avec 3 défend
bien tout il y avait foule prend h6
d'ailleurs le plus drôle c'est que
j'avais vu en plus et juste avant sur
qu'il n'allait pas prendre comme ça peu
importe on va mettre le foin f4 comme ça
on va venir essayer de s'emparer du pion
g3 au cas où
bon là il veut nous poser des problèmes
qui ne va pas mais joue pas mal hein
pour 13 124 franchement c'est pas mal on
ne va pas s'embêter va lui reprendre son
pion j'aurais vraiment dû faire
photographier tout à l'heure alors
mettre le foin f4 comme ça on bloque
tout il ya ça qui emprise asaki emprise
hockey y défend on va prendre au bout
d'un moment ici on va prendre là bas je
récupère dame français si c'est gagner
et gagner le cavalier h 6 allée fin
tiens on va faire d'un v8 échec c'est
marrant pour le faire tomber
allez on est reparti
on rejoue chirag tu passes une mauvaise
chose de rejouer un chirac parce que
c'est un adversaire qui peut être
dangereux au classement nantes connaît
ça nous permet de se perdre entre
guillemets dollar était à chaque fois et
va rejouer cette variante là donc on va
tout près move
à noter que même quand on prêt vous en
fais ton mais on met une seconde à jouer
en fait donc c'est pas mal moins qu'ils
jouent pas vite c'est moi qui lag
je l'aï beaucoup je n'ouvrais kf5
c'était pas mal joué et il connaît bien
cette variante en plus voilà et bien
battus tout à l'heure mais mais il est
dangereux alors va faire h5 peut pas
faire de mal de toutes les filles hasard
soit affaibli on va peut-être mettre le
fond angers 5 par la suite
pour le moment on ne peut pas on va le
magicien en d2 comme celle ci fait g5 on
pourra prendre défaire f4 peut-être tu
vas être la tour en c1 ce n'est jamais
une mauvaise idée en cette variante jeu
mais très vaillants g5 sur échec s'en va
chasser la dame et on va venir essayer
de passer par la colonne ces voix là on
va les clous et on va jouer le clouage
maintenant bon jouer un coup à gauche un
coup à gauche un coup à droite
ok mais ça ça marche pas parce qu'il
faut prendre quatre et on maintient
l'attaqué maintenant à faire pour ses
sets donc c'était pas mal tenté un sa
petite tactique mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya trop de trous dans sa position
et que forcément ça doit le payer paye t
trou dames et fille sont minces d'am-dam
at elle doit refaire tout rêve c'est ton
affaire d'âme h 8 et on va le maté
envoyé trop trop de trop de trous sur
cases noires tout est sûre case blanche
et donc chirac une nouvelle fois un coup
pas mal qui joue pas mal cette cette
variante
mais qui se retrouvent avec beaucoup de
trous sur noir et ont réussi comme ça le
mal qu'on tournait alors on joue contre
tactis c'est les mêmes les mêmes
adversaires j'arrive plus à parler
qu'est ce que c'est que ça que dont le
que dans le tome précédent
à noter un qui est un joueur à 14 ans
qui est toujours à notre poursuite
il est chaud il est chaud patate beiit
il est simplement à trois points
derrière
tu as un 14 500 qui sont hyper chaud
parce que c'est à dire qu'ils font à peu
près le même tournoi que moi et donc qui
gagnent à peu près toutes leurs parties
essaient de faire g34 venir déloger ce
cavalier qui a probablement les verts h8
donc b5 généralement dans les positions
de structures type française pas très
bon parce que ce cavalier va se
retrouver en prise dans pas mal de
warrants clore ici cavaliers h8 on va
pouvoir faire dame ces deux on me l'a
évoqué je ne touche à rien et l'idée
c'est sûr qu'à la chute je vais faire
dame ces deux jeux mais assez fou proche
7 mater d'avancé 6 bon il donne du matos
ça c'est plutôt sympa mais ils régleront
pas le problème de ce cavalier manqué il
le donne
il est d'humeur il est d'humeur père
noël il faut être quatre comme ça on va
menacer des découvertes en être le lot
tours en c1 on va venir comme ça quelque
part
viser la dame alors pour apprendre du
cavalier comme ça on va la visée comme
ça on va l'arvise est comme ça aussi
j'ai envie de te dire c'est de la double
visée est très attention à ce que tu
fais hop voilà révisée avec la tour
c'est horrible on va la réviser notre
foi avec la tour sera rude cette dame
elle passe la pire partie de sa vie et
maintenant vallée le maté à la brusque à
la brutale à l'ailé brut
hop on brutalise ouais c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal parce que tactics 35,53
c'était un adversaire potentiel mais -
cb it beats le mec à 14,75 a qui me fait
peur lui ai quand même
il a neuf sur dix il est quand même très
chaud à lecce plésiosaures espèce de
dinosaure plaisir et ce plésiosaures
mais avec les dinosaures se décale parce
qu'en fait ça pas forcément à
grand-chose il rejoue une deuxième fois
la même pièce dans l'ouverture
voilà on va faire cinq comprendre le
centre jouer de manière conventionnelle
mettre le fou en d ici son valet on va
on va aller on va les jouer
si féroce qu'on va faire 4 ok va essayer
d'aller cacher sa dame
on va essayer lui choper la dame et
voilà la dame qui est chopé et attention
attention c'est le beau joue la tour qui
tombe temps d'abandonner pourchasse
plésiosaures voilà bien vu jeunesse
plésiosaures on prend un petit peu de
distance avec le deuxième à léon
victimise le tournoi on victimise la
bullet arena riscal alors à faire un
contre gambie albin alors là dessus je
passe quand il faut prendre je connais
pas trop un ça va la deuxième fois de ma
vie que je le joue
on va prendre en fait j'ai envie de
jouer avec a6b 5
ces cinq maintenant je patiente c5 mais
bon tête je vais mettre le foin eu 6
dans un deuxième temps cette crise et si
ce qui est b4 kaïs et 2 du pib de caïds
et 3 aussi peut être une idée que me
permettre de m'en emparer de la paire de
ouf on met le fou russie sont à préparer
grand roque
on va prévue vers un jour un peu plus
vite et en d3 quand même bien envie de
le mettre ça me permettra de libérer
éventuellement la case d3 pour pour le
fou au cas où kg 5 m'embête un peu c'est
ce qu'ils jouent donc c'est plutôt pas
mal joué
je veux faire du cahier j'écarte
maintenant cette fève 3 serait pas mal
joué ouais c'est pas mal joué ils jouent
pas mal là mon adversaire
on va mettre le cap des 7 on va lire
passé vers eux cinq ça va permettre de
renforcer cavaliers de renforcer le pion
et six f4 j'aurais kg qu'attend tout cas
pointe pour le moment ils sont je veux
faire québec at échec et venir passer
celui-là ici peut-être refaire tour 17
on peut passer le on peut changer de
cavale si jamais on va mettre un échec
on mettre un deuxième échec
je vais peut-être passer par du cas
valls et de après elle n'a pas trop de
casse pour son roi en même temps ok on
va prendre avec le pion et maintenant on
aura on assuré le pion en d3 maintenant
on va faire un petit échec ramener la
tour en des huit films avaient dû
cavalli ces deux échecs qui était très
beau ça marche encore c'est la
fourchette
il va déjà falloir abandonner pour notre
pour notre cher adversaire qui est en
pls victimisation du tournoi mais c'est
d'aller faire le match de l'escalier un
spécialiste international comme vous le
savez je pense que je vais mater de
manière assez fort c'est en faisant tour
à trois au prochain il y avait match
y'avait matin par ap il y avait matin
pas bien mais il y était le mat de
l'escalier on l'avait réussi plus ou
moins trouvé notre rythme bas et le
deuxième a enfin chuté sabrais destine
ait n était pas mal classé lui attention
attention attention un joueur qui nous
vient de singapour faut pas se relâcher
là j'ai envie de faire un perfect je
suis chaud patate
je suis chaud pour le perfect aller face
candidate des quatre cavaliers boom qui
arrivant j'ai quatre le grand roque le
pont des quatre qui tombe allez on y va
aller mais qu on y croit on est parti
pour le perfect même pas essayé d'aller
gagner le pion même si c'était une bonne
idée je veux juste aller mater voilà on
va on va aller mater à l'ailé brut
j'espère que toutes les brutes sont dans
le tchat hop on a brutalisé lecavalier
f3 c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini
alors voilà on il veut rentrer dans la
finale on va laisser rentrer dans la
finale finale avec une pièce de plus on
en gagne
on peut en jouer tous les jours à l'ebu
mon pouce comme des malades on reste des
brutes
allez hop on laisse on laisse faire ces
5 s'il a envie mais problème c'est qu'on
reste des grosses brutes allait s'en
prendre à son fou ici fait bessin fait
jusqu'à vallier à cinq mètres le four f6
on va taper le pion des quatre alors a
fait une belle poussée assez d'efforts
devraient restés vains
prendre ça ici
d'accord il aura vraiment pas mal
résisté à propositions qu'il avait on va
prendre à trois ça a commencé à faire du
matos comme ça quand même tout ça epyon
ça sert à quelque chose aussi
ça fait quand même pas mal de pions ça
fait pas mal de matos up pas jouer un
peu avec le feu
avec el fuego un échec deux échecs on
est là tous rangs b4 et pas cavalier 5
mat pour le moment on va devoir prendre
comme ça allez on va s'amuser avec un
vin ça va plus marcher
ce qu'on peut mater un problème c'est
qu'on va jamais matté comme ça il ya
malheureusement toujours un mais on peut
ramener le cavalier hk tes joues f5
maintenant
bon ça m'a toujours pas ça gagne 1
cavale de plus allez c'est reparti douze
sur douze
le premier poursuivant c'est un petit
peu fait lâcher alors jouerie jacques
allez on va on continue et on continue
on y va on joue pour le 100 % retient
pas du tout une variante moins taxés à
main ça allait faire ses 4 5 5 avant ok
j'ai fait l'idiot par rapport à la vente
que je voulais jouer on va prendre des
fers h3
personne ne m'a dépassé maintenant le
chat 1400 viens de te dépasser ça va on
gère pour le moment que ma joue avec à 3
l'impression que je fais un peu
n'importe quoi du cavalière à 5 heures
randonnée peut être pénible mais bon à
faire p 4 mètres la tour en c1
je vais 5 quand même rire est panne qui
arrive qui unit bonsoir à tous bon soir
est bahn va mettre la tour en vain le
foin f4 bref 80 pas pouvoir mais l'atout
romand c'est important de pouvoir mettre
le foin f1 pour un peu protégés il va
voir filer à lille va faire filer de
l'autre côté tour d un préparé un petit
peu allez on va préparer le beau jeu et
puis cavalier a eu 5
on va jouer avec jets karaté karaté f5
alors affaire f4 et f5 on va faire
pousser on va faire juger quatre allez
on va faire le beau jeu c'est un peu
dangereux ce qui peut faire d'un match 4
et il peut venir un peu nous martyriser
mais on va va faire le beau temps sur
d'un match 4 ça va ça tient qu'elle va
prendre ce pas le beau jeu nous on n'a
pas trop le choix à venir ont des six
pouces et g4 c'est de rentrer tous les
pions on va prendre là et on va prendre
on va faire un sacrifice de qualité et
on va sacrifier une deuxième qualité on
voulait faire le beau jeu depuis de
talent voilà double sacrifice de carlos
à il le prend pas il ne le prend pas
dommage il ne prend pas nos cadeaux
on a vraiment le problème de lag auquel
cavaliers se fait enfermer par espèce de
mur de pions et on va recycler le fou
mars mars mars mars quel idiot après les
doigts en gagne autant pourquoi les
noirs ont gagné autant que s'est il
passé
que s'est-il passé ce que c'est moi qui
est arrivé mais ce que j'avais encore
quinze secondes et que j'ai perdu autant
pour casser mon strict j'avais encore du
temps sur la pendule et et tout d'un
coup plus de temps heureusement qu'on
gagne le tournoi noté alligator qui
finit troisième vierge les 43 points
mais quelle langue incroyable il restait
10 secondes et tout d'un coup 0
heureusement ça fait d'être au préjudice
à l'onf il est quand même premier on
finit quand même premiers mais bon
c'était tendu c'était tendu
alors est ce qu'on réalise est de les re
mystifié allez on en refaire ouais
j'avais bien dit seconderez jeu fait
mystifier avec 10 secondes
c'était assez mis si je sais pas ce qui
s'est passé
parce qu'ils écrivent choisi chaque
point comme
je suis l'âme qu'il adore regarder nos
stream
merci je suis l'âme et connerré temps je
suis pas encore remis du je me suis pas
encore remis du flag fantastique la
partie juste horrible je sais pas si je
vais pas perdre en fait c'était juste of
pain est quand même très mal je ne sais
pas comment on va s'en sortir parce
qu'on est quand même complètement raide
mais bon là n'est imparti était très
très spécial on va dire ça comme ça je
ne comprends pas trop ce qui s'est passé
mais je sens que j'ai des difficultés de
connexions massive est vraiment de la
merde dans cette partie c'est
complètement subi tout sur tout et tous
complètement débile en fait à cormelles
monde il y aussi ont mis lui aussi a
fini par payer
la précédente toi je vais porter reprend
d'ailleurs fait tu perds dir est
direction trois secondes je ne sais pas
c'est parce que j'envoie du flux sur
internet
voilà ça c'est cadeau ça serait bien que
la versa abandonne
il poussé mon option je passe du mal à
motiver la danse est parti aujourd'hui
je vais te ramener mon autre qu'ayant f5
en fait d'aller mater à l'ancien
cavalier cinq dames des deux dames 3 6
ça m'a l'air assez efficace comme
manière de continuer la partie à l'essai
mais saddam ici comment je vais être un
cavalier en échec et je vais aller
attaquer ce adamek avec le cavale comme
ça si saddam s'en va je ferai de la
mâche six matches mais s'il fait dame b
4 ok il fait ça là je vais prendre ça
j'ai dû réussir à mater mais bon je suis
pas prêt il continue à jouer ça c'est
désagréable
mais là c'est le point 4 mais c'est dur
de se motiver sur ces parties là c'est
dur à se motiver parce que enfin c'est
quand même une tour de plus et enfin à
quoi ça sert de jouer
comme on est pas mal mais bon il faut y
fait vraiment con con un meilleur lag
pas pour le moment ça le fait il va
novye gorki chiffre en dessous skins
naïve noces team no stream sera vite ça
c'est passive à ivan est pas si bagne
alors qu'est ce qu'on y fait mais que
nous fûmes scandinave allez on va lui
faire caillasser 3 on va le jouer avant
taxes b4 allez on est chauds à il faut
d'amd 8 quel dommage qu'elles
demandaient des parties pour la vente
avec des cats pour lui pour lui choper
la dame
alors voilà on va attaquer partout
hop
le foie je le sentais venir cette petite
prise du fou je la sentais venir cette
prise du fou alors espérer qu'ils rock
qui ont valu faire cavalier des cinq
boom la diagonale à aller on va mater
jusqu'en la suite s'est pas mal passée
contre adversaire grecque
pastor qui demande vise inquiet rousski
izik gagnage n'a pas tort une bâtisse
hitchock pastor qui est chaud patate
dans le chat car elle a demandé si ça va
falloir chip et isole là il va faire le
défoncer par me le dézinguer le gip et
isole peut-être mieux faire mais bon je
pense à un bordel pas croyable
composition était juste simplement
gagnant probablement parce que du coup
je laisse le pion des cinq affaires
réussissent heureusement qu'il ya pas
fou de tour des huit j'aurais pu le
rater sa tour s'échappe
on va mettre le cavalier en d4 a quand
même essayé de le de la punir cette tour
puni mois puni moi te punir
j'ai envie de faire à six wi fi cas les
français si je vais prendre ici et s'il
prend au bk je vais prendre un bekkat en
plus j'ai ouvert la l'accolade de la
tour là là là je suis très heureux la
valette où tout allait tout content là
bas et on va lui faire du fer du leff 6
faut juste un peu plus vite un même on
est tranquille sympa la 7 tours en l2
mines elle domine the game domine le
game m sale affaire sept tours ces huit
tours c3 on va la jouer facile si bien
le judo avec le fonds a fait retour à
deux ou même pas on va échanger et puis
on va ramener le tour à huit a fait
retour à trois échecs
il va faire froid eux deux on va faire
tour à deux un retour à 2 quand même on
va prendre et maintenant on va prendre
âge de ça c'est le beau jeu et on va
faire une petite fourchette up
spock et support qu il va faire échec
cette fois c'est sûr ça l'échec il était
écrit d'avancé maintenant on va ramasser
il dira à massada ram assad a batu
ramasser voilà non mes proches et perdu
encore j'ai perdu autant j'ai encore
perdu autant qu'est ce que c'est que ça
non mais c'est moi qui hallucine ou pas
il pourra jouer faire autant non mais
attendez mais qu'est ce que c'est enfin
pourquoi j'ai perdu autant cette partie
mais je ne comprends pas en fait je
comprends juste pas enfin julien qui est
du match mais a quand même écrit qu'il
me reste du temps la pendule face du
courant vous quoi je perds en fait
non mais enfin ça c'est fâcheux énervé
je suis très énervé je suis en pls je
tombe autant on ne sait pas pourquoi
mais je ne vais pas mettre ma cas d'une
femme vierge j'envoie du stream tout
marche bien fin je ne vais pas défoncer
mon forfait 4g en cinq minutes parce
qu'on ne sait pas proche de pair ouais
je ne comprend pas faim je ne comprends
pas je suis très énervé il me restait il
m'a laissé beaucoup de temps enfin pas
pris ma stupeur
moi je suis vraiment pls là je joue très
mal
enfin je ne sais pas pourquoi est-ce que
je suis tombé malesza mes nerfs on va
sacrifier des pièces va tout va lancer
et on en a marre on en a gros si
j'échoue g5 et préfinale et boum
y en a marre il y en a marre on en a
gros noms mais j'ai déjà fait du
streaming et jouer en bullet sais c'est
pas la première fois mais là j'en ai
gros boum j'en ai marre je ne sais pas
peut-être je n'ai plus de temps enfin
c'est le suspense en fait ok
heureusement qu on mate
non il faut jouer plus vite c'est sympa
c'est ça oh non non non non attends là
ces ouvertures interdite avec le fait
une ruiz géré au bout d'un moment ça va
il ne fait pas une auris complète il a
senti là il a vu le stream
il a senti qu'on savait que c'était
l'ouverture interdit s'il n'a pas fait
mince et cavaliers ici je joue pas super
bien dirigé deux échecs en plus mais bon
j'ai un peu de mal faut que je me
reprenne
on va tous poussé va se détendre en
poussant les pions de façon à faire j'ai
cinq ans après on fait stratégie anti
jeu comme ça va faire petit rock très
très content a repoussé les pions à fond
la voix l'échoppé cette merde à faire
flamber 5 allée du cloud et
mais
mais bon on va réussir à clouer son
cavalier normalement grâce à son cou
tour à s'inquiéter complètement inutile
mais bon malheureusement ne réussit pas
malheureusement on n'est pas très bien
là mais bon je suis vraiment en pls donc
je ne sais pas combien il reste deux
temps ça a beaucoup plus de temps que
moi nous ne savons pas moi c'est simple
comme ça vaut rien
même réussi à choper un pion mais
normalement
non le truc c'est que le cavalier va
être assez mauvais pour stopper ce pion
non le problème c'est qu'en fait un peu
plus de temps comme ses collègues de ouf
je m'attends moindre moment à ce qu'on a
ce qu'on me dise que j'ai perdu autant
en fait le mec était voilà on a perdu
autant un furet c'est du temps c'est
impossible c'est impossible nous ne
pouvons rien faire
nous ne pouvons rien faire
c'est impossible
en fait on fait un double lagon puis son
lac déjà pendant les parties en plus on
se fera en double lag c'est bien 5
secondes et c'était bien complètement
gagnant mais bien dominé la finale mais
bon je sais pas si d'autres personnes
ont ce bug mais très difficile pour moi
nous sommes en pls pour que faire ça
arrive mais les informaticiens vous
réglez ça mais bon c'est déjà ce point
comme se venge
j'ai mis trop de joueurs en pls
ils ont décidé de me contre attaquer ces
mecs me donne des pions pas refusé puis
est bien protégé mettre la dame en h4 en
fait je les avais mater en force et sur
100 à faire quelquefois et fils comme ça
on est dans ma chute matt hop c'est
assez joli ça bon bah voilà comme ça il
n'y a pas de lag comme ça c'est bon
allez ils ont vraiment réussi à mettre
en pls stratégie de chasse - comme pour
le mettre en pls sur frf 5 on va espérer
qu'ils prennent comme saddam à cinq
échecs à le piège c'est ce qu'on valait
puisqu'on veut prendre ici non ça ne
marche pas la voir revenir ici on va
échanger les dames non il veut pas
échangé hockey
tant pis pour eux m'atteler tout soit
prêt faire un remix de la chanson des
pokémon quoi tchatche.com ma télé tous
africains en b3 bon c'était complètement
stupide scouts pib 3
je suis allée m'enfermer tout seul pour
aller le maté avait peut-être que je
peux faire des saints cannes en mai à
tours prend il ya pas mal troll alors
y'a pas mat ce que l'on va revenir
aïe aïe aïe je mens pls à cause de cette
pendule
mais peut-être pu faire tour c8 et forcé
le mat quand même tient peut-être obligé
de faire tour c'est un buffet retour ces
8es maintenant il a poussé 6a fallait
prendre à 8 en premier il fallait
prendre à 8 en premier en fait donc et
on est quand même gagnants mais il s'en
sort alors de faire flamber cinq matches
maintenant c'est malte c'était assez
jolie d'ailleurs c'est un joli match les
gens allaient là on tombe toujours
nouveau boxer on ne rejoue que contre le
même adversaire
mais le match était très très esthétique
j'espère que vous avez apprécié je passe
je vais le mettre dans le jazz que vous
aviez apprécié le mat
moi je trouvais sympa bon là en fait un
peu n'importe quoi une nouvelle fois
sous qu'on essaie de jouer vite ans on a
retenu alors si je suis en arène mais je
me retape lui-même adversaire
maintenant je suis plus en arène si je
suis en arrête je sais pas en fait il
fut en arène ou pas maintenant je suis
plus en arène pourquoi je suis plus en
arène pourquoi je fus en arène
je comprends pas en fait
ouais nan mais c'est vrai j'étais en
aréna l'instant je suis pas que doit-on
faire ça là on va la perdre mais bon on
s'en fiche on est plus en arène de toute
façon je comprends pas en fait je suis
en perez total bahut nommément à la
limite cela on peut la perdre on s'en
fout complètement fait surtout là je
m'en fous complètement parti n'a aucune
importance c'est vrai je suis sorti de
cette arène moins bon
enfin elle est le maté ce petit cocon
pas faire trop précise pas ce qu'il fait
je prends là il va nous mater on va se
faire mater mais bon ce pas là on est
plus en arène pourquoi s'en sortir
l'allemande est de nouveau tombé mais
qu'est ce que c'est pourquoi on est de
nouveau tombé non non on aurait perdu
quand même mais je ne comprends rien en
fait je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
maintenant hhbc j'ai pas du tout rage
quit je sais je sais pas comment c'est
tombé j'ai du mal clic et quelque part
on se reprend une ruine pour pas changer
voyez le maté c'est une matelas ruiz
quand même sur m2 peut-être ailleurs
on va prendre ça là on va prendre ça là
on pas trop ce qui s'est passé mais j'ai
du déjà vu mais j'ai du mystique quelque
part
qu'est ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on
souffre
qu'est-ce qui fait celui-là j'ai rien à
voir c'est si ce qu'est ce que mon temps
s'affiche correctement je fais mes
adversaires ça c'est un truc dont je
suis en jeu seraient que je serais
curieux de savoir si si le temps
s'affiche correctement chez mes
adversaires en fait ou si tout d'un coup
je tombe tout le temps en fait je ne
fait que tomber de mr freeze inattendue
on verra bien comment ça se passe mais
on pas évident cela nous aurait coûté
cher accueillait ya peut-être un abonné
de la chaîne qui va gagner le tournoi
les gâteaux on va réussir à gagner il va
nous venger non ce qui se passe à eagle
n'est pas facile cette histoire de la
gare vraiment surtout c'est pas vraiment
parents du lagon voit combien il nous
reste deux temps ce qui rend la
situation encore plus complexe
non mais a clairement un complot contre
moi c'est ça me paraît évident ça me
paraît complètement évidente c'est un
complot et toutes les vidéos de paix
alès ils ont décidé de me mettre en pls
je ne sais pas combien de temps j'ai un
je ne sais pas
seyman en plus on est très très mal
alors tu pas qu'on va s'en sortir de
cette partie mais bon question seat ont
encore du temps enfin ça aurait été
marrant en tout cas
parce que c'était ce que c'est on
adversaire qui est une problème de
connexion est ce que c'est moi c'est la
question que je me pose à la c'était mon
adversaire alors lui tout à l'heure nous
a fait tomber à matignon refait une
ruine est comme ça admettons affaires g5
c'est bien vissé avec notre fou 3g c'est
peut-être monter le roi en jeu ici ça on
va monter à la volée j'aimerais bien
perdre une vraie partie dans ce stream
ce que j'ai l'impression de perdre des
fausses parti depuis tout à l'heure et
sans admettre comme ça la russie clé le
fou met le foie ans et 7
j'aimerais bien perdre une vraie partie
pas perdre sur des flag improbable
cependant je pense que mise à part les
fly improbables je n'ai pas eu de
devrait défaite
prendre son pion fortiori c'est une
donnée un pion à part refusé à pousser
notre pions
moi
comme il nous reste deux temps ne sais
pas j'espérais qu'il nous en reste assez
j'ai envie de vous dire ça comme ça on
va mettre la dame au 1 c'est pas mal
joué ça
la fouille b6 comme ça on attaque la
dame c'est joli ça fout b6 et la dame
est cloué à mince maintenant ce mois ci
peut reprendre du cavalier mais problème
c'est qu'on va perdre autant une
nouvelle fois brême sais que suis sûr
qu'on a plus de temps et qu'on va et
qu'on va se faire flasher ma position
est une lutte face on a fait n'importe
quoi quand même c'est qu'on va se faire
flinguer fly et on a probablement plus
du tout le temps voilà c'est ça ces
nouveaux faits fly et c'est dommage que
j'aurais peut-être pu la gagner mais
j'étais trop stressée par par la pendule
est fou ici c'était pas mal joué et là
il y avait juste dame pranger 3 en fait
complètement ridicule mais j'étais trop
stressée par la fausse pendule bah du
coup c'est cool je sens un abonné qui
gagne
mais ouais c'est avec le stream ça fait
un buzz malheureusement je serai bien
savoir si des gens qui jouent le l'aréna
en le même le même problème que moi
mais là oui c'est devant une foule et si
c'était vraiment jolie pour la peine
vous pouvez si c'était vraiment jolie
menacé le menacer la dame et y avait le
cavalier qui était en prise
c'était assez sympa
il va aussi d'apprendre un prérequis
menacé après 1,3 dollar sert ou pas tu
vas vers le système sis ou la reine de
base en fait tu préfères le système
d'arène je trouve que c'est plus marrant
pour les tournées sur internet
mais bon il faut le temps que ça soit
mis au point
j'ai serré un petit peu à un petit peu
plus tard sans stream en fait il ça
l'fait aussi en tout cas c'est sûr c'est
qu'avec le stream c'est juste pas
possible
bon à part jouer d'autres partis sur
l'arène on va finir par faire quelques
boulettes normaux
finir par quelques bulles est normand
c'est vrai qu'on avait un gros handicap
parce que je pense qu'on perd un peu on
perdait un peu de temps aussi avec le
lag et on perdait doublement du temps en
fait c'est de récupérer quelques points
et gérant bien su savoir en fait si
jamais on sent que c'est plus fluide en
fait quand je ne suis pas sûr la reine
seront donc là les partis sont plus
fluides
parce que vous en pensez alors cette
histoire là est ce que c'était horrible
je me rappelle plus
je constate un truc assez mauvais en
fait pour les noirs mais quand
l'adversaire joue à ouais ça en blitz
il a réussi à me piéger donc bravo à lui
à ce niveau là je veux un petit truc
piège pour pour le bullet ça pas mal
fonctionné
il faut avouer un peu la tête dans le
seau en plus à ok donc avec brave
oiseaux alligator alors qui a gagné ce
tournoi on va prendre ça et on va faire
ça alors est ce qu'on veut faire quoi
que ce soit ici
vraiment assez c'est horrible je sais
juste même pas comment continuer cette
partie abandonnée mais c'est bien finir
quand même là l'esprit n'y ait plus pour
le moment on va essayer de bien finir
les ondes je vais encore 10 minutes
jusqu'à l'importante on va essayer de
finir correctement parce que la femme ça
commence à être exagéré oh non faut pas
faire d'un 25 sur des cadres direct aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe ces multiples
défaites auront eu raison de moi c'est
de jouer correctement je vous pas
vraiment bien à 5 battue pas dire que je
joue beaucoup mieux hein mais pas l'air
très fameux quand même pas l'air
exceptionnelle en profiter pour faire
grand roc de ce quartier qui est passé
par des deux
il faut qu'on essaie de faire quelque
chose mais là c'est vraiment pas évident
c'est vraiment pas évident bon essayer
de prendre angers 4 on va essayer
d'aller gagner on ne peut pas on va
faire ça
c'est super kf de au prochain dans sa
marche plus d'un an
maintient aussi fait qu'il prend au sein
mais peut-être le temps de faire dame
croit f2 ou alors on adam problème deux
cavaliers g3 maths c'est sympa tu n'as
pas le temps de reprendre en fait en 3
qu'on avait le temps de faire match
aller c'est bien sûr quelques victoires
plutôt jouer des cadres et le truc moins
tactique je sens que j'ai un adversaire
qui est assez tactique à faire jusqu'à
trois mètres la tam ont eu deux on a
poussé e5 waroquet les cavaliers en
bessin caillassé 4 on va prendre prendre
qui est catastrophe
quelle catastrophe a quand même qu'il y
ait des six échecs on va jouer sur le
clouage du fou pour aller lui choper
sont fous bessette
voilà ça c'est pas mal pour nous enfin
quelque chose qui tourne en notre faveur
petites tactiques est
je suis redevenu qui n'a pas le même
problème j'imagine donc ça va être
pendant qu'on stream l'aréna doit pas du
tout ma recherche et pacy s'il pu l'être
là va marcher avec avec le stream ou pas
mais en tout cas ce sera la première
fois que ça arrive mais japs que c'est
beaucoup plus fluide parce que je suis
en train de faire ici
je suis en train de mal jouer mais ça
devrait suffire à faire qu'il y ait cinq
cavaliers ktk les français c'est un
caron pas s'emmerder la tour en premier
potager le pion aux cavaliers hd2 b3 on
va les shops espions l'a finalement on
va pousser alors en c6 mais ça va pas
gagner
il ya des jours comme ça c'est si dur
il ya des jours c'est dur comme je dis
parfois c'est dans les jours comme ça
que que c'est le plus intéressant au
final parce qu'on essaye vraiment de de
se battre contre nous mêmes beaucoup
d'émotion beaucoup d'émotions négatives
donc c'est d'autant plus difficile mais
c'est d'autant plus intéressant permet
d'avoir à trouver des ressources a
fortiori
la demande est simple assurer chèque ça
va être bien ça on va mettre le cavalier
là à ok ça lag de partout c'est
désespérant jeu sont souvent arrêtés les
bulles est ici je sais pas c est ma
connexion internet ou je ne sais pas il
se passe quelque chose mais à quelque
chose qui ne va pas on aura perdu face
au travers duquel la quasi totalité des
partis de la même manière ça doit être
un problème est qu'avec ma connexion
j'imagine
j'imagine sans rien que ma connexion
en fait ce qui met le nom en fait ce qui
est marrant c'est qu'en fait là il dit
qu'il me restait trois secondes mais
c'est très bizarre en fait lines il
reste deux secondes mais il reste deux
secondes 8 la 3 secondes 1 3 seconde
catherine secondes 5
je sais pas ce qui fait que ce que l'on
en fait j'ai quasiment tout près move et
après à partir de là la parole je n'ai
pas joué school en une seconde j'ai
prélevé d'amd 5
non il faudra que je remonte ce
classement il faudrait que je remonte ce
classement stream
il va falloir que je me venge sur chaque
point comme que je les mette en pls mon
nid en pls avec ça il va falloir que je
les mette en pls il va falloir que je
les contremaîtres en paix est là c'est
trop abuser ils méritent d'être mis en
place
donc on verra ça on verra ça plus tard
et bah n'oubliez pas demain soir le
tournoi de discorde dont qui sera pas
commenté mais il sera là il y aura le
tour un discours demain soir à 20h05 ou
20h15 jeu puisque 20h15 ou 20h53
discorde enfin peu importe ural temps à
discorde et donc vous pourrez suivre
et moi je vais essayer de le tester tout
ça et voir voir comment ça se passe sur
des questions je reste encore deux
petites minutes ça reste encore de
petites minutes en live et puis après on
va être on est parti après on sera
partis et merci or suit le stream quand
même c'est quand même sympa d'essayer
les arénas je vous conseille vraiment de
d'essayer d'y jouer
c'est assez sympa donc je vous je vous
recommande vraiment de tester vous ne
direz si ça marche chez vous si vous
avez le même problème mais on m'a dit
dans le chatt quelque part que que
c'était pareil pour tous les streamer
merci valent des amis qui me dit que
c'était cool malgré le lay ouais c'était
un peu frustrant mais ça va on s'est
quand même bien amusé un ça arrive c'est
pas grave c'est que des parties d'échecs
sur internet
donc on va pas se prendre la tête pour
sa bad trip 90 lui ni moi j'y go by
paille à toi passent une agréable soirée
est bon
ça nous empêchera pas de vrais sites
jouer à l'engagement on est on est on
est pas on n'est pas écoeuré on va on va
revenir voir on va de nouveau se battre
mais ils ont mérité comme une petite
vidéo de pls ils vont la mériter cette
vidéo ils vont la mériter cette vidéo
ils vont mériter la pls bombe à écouter
les mecs je vous laisse je reconnais
plus de questions et je vous dis à
bientôt sur la chaîne
ciao